All right.
So
we've been talking about
a code of representations in some sense
of symbolic representation and I've been
trying to guide you through some
developing understanding of that code of
symbolic representation so that as we
progress through the course,
you'll have the ground rules in some
sense for interpreting all the different
theories that we encounter.
And uh,
we're going to continue that today.
This is the last lecture on sort of pre
psychoanalytic conceptions of
personality.
And then we moved to piaget and then to
you.
So
the first thing I tried to point out to
you was that social primates like us
likely have a cognitive structure that's
based on social categories.
And that when our cognitive systems
elaborate it up enough to start thinking
about the world in more abstract terms
beyond our immediate environment,
there's a high probability that we
learned,
we used the same cognitive structures
that had evolved to begin the process of
abstract conceptualization.
And so in some sense you could say we
used our knowledge of personality to
start to understand the external world
based on the initial axiomatic
assumption.
It's not a cognitive assumption.
It was a perceptual assumption that the
world was like a personality.
And we do this automatically.
So I want to show you a little video
here that's quite a famous video.
Um,
it shows you how easily you can abstract
out and narrative from the most abstract
of events.
Okay.
So watch what happens.
Okay,
let's watch that one more time.
So it's something like,
we'll go over it again.
It's something like the little circle,
the poor little circle is trying to
escape and when it does,
the bad gray triangle comes up and sort
of steals it.
And then a blue triangle has a little
scrap with the gray triangle and you
know,
puts the little yellow or the little
circle back into its safe and closure.
Right?
And so the,
the reason that that demonstration was
developed was to indicate or two and
also to task how little information you
really needed,
how low resolution the information was
that you needed in order to perceive,
to directly perceive something that was
like a narrative.
So,
you know,
and that's a relatively complicated
narrative.
All things considered for a square at
two triangles.
And a circle interacting for maybe three
or four seconds.
So you know,
the,
the point of this demonstration is to
indicate just exactly how prepared you
are to read the world in narrative
terms.
So
yeah,
Laurie,
okay.
Now I had talked to you about these
figures before and I was trying to make,
so here,
here's kind of an overview of what I'm
attempting to describe to you.
So the one,
there's one category of representation
that has to do with the territory that
you inhabit and that you understand
that's primarily social territory and it
tends to be symbolized by masculine and
usually like older male symbols.
So that's the patriarchal structure.
I really think what it is is a,
it's a personified representation of the
dominance hierarchy structure.
So if remember the lion king,
you know the pride rock thing.
So the pride rock is sort of associated
with the,
with the symbols father.
And so that's,
that's that category of symbol is the
symbol that I'm talking about.
So he used that,
that high place on a mountain as an
indicator of dominance structure.
You saw that at the opening of the lion
king movie where all the animals come,
they gather around,
they all bow before the,
the rock with the king on top of it.
And the king,
like the lion is a symbol generally a
symbol of something like solar power
because the lion is a top Predator,
it's apex Predator and it lives in
Africa under the sun and it has a main,
that's sort of like a son.
And then later in the lion king will
actually see this today you'll see the
father lion who fossa.
Yes,
he appears in the sky with a solar halo
around him.
So,
so that's the masculine category.
And then the feminine category I told
you a little about a bit about is a more
chaotic category and it's a,
it's a chaotic and plastic category out
of which new forms emerge.
And then one of the categories that we
haven't talked about is the category of
the individual and the individual is the
hero and hero stories and is the
initiate and initiatory routines.
And so the hero is the person who is
attempting to become a complete
biological and historical entity
personality so that they're capable not
only of,
of,
of um,
adopting independent existence,
but if adopting independent existence
that's productive and that's productive
in a way that's also a benefit to the
community.
So it's a particular pattern of
development and that that needs to be
catalyzed by human societies because in
order for a society to,
to maintain its structure and for the
people within it to thrive,
the developing individuals have to
mature to the point where they can take
care of themselves in a way that doesn't
disrupt the whole social structure.
And so that's the path.
It's a natural path for human beings.
I would say to some degree because we're
such intensely social creatures,
but because we're also quite malleable
and complex and also grounded in history
and cultural creatures,
it's also something that has to be
taught both from the perspective of
invitation and explicitly.
And so a lot of initiation rights,
for example,
are predicated on the idea that you take
the person out of their childhood
context,
you destroy their personality usually as
a consequence of some cause,
a traumatic encounter and then you
refill them with the cultural norms and
that makes them an adult.
And so,
you know,
to some degree that's what you guys are
doing in a very slow way.
When you make the transition from high
school say to university or that
transition from high school to a,
to a job.
We don't,
in our culture,
we don't have the kind of abrupt
ceremonies though that are designed to
catalyze that transformation.
And you know,
maybe that's an okay thing and,
and then maybe it's not an okay thing.
I mean one of the things that Freud
pointed out,
and he's absolutely right about this,
is that because human beings have such a
long dependency period,
it's not that easy for us to grow up.
And sometimes it takes a shock in order
for that to happen.
And so one of the potential problems
with having a dependency period as long
as the human dependency period is that
it never ends and that you stay immature
forever.
And really I believe that that's the
central old problem that Freud talked
about.
And I believe also that it's a real
problem.
Now whether Freud formulated it,
you know,
with precise accuracy,
that's a different story.
But you know,
you've got to give the guy a break.
At least he formulated and it,
and it's,
I mean I was much more impressed with
Freud and eda pull theorizing after I
did clinical work for a long time
because a large number of my patients,
their primary problem is getting the
hell out of their family.
They just can't do it.
And so for them the world is the family.
It's the only thing that matters.
It's often parental opinion or something
like that and they just cannot break
free of it.
So you know,
initiation ceremonies in part were
designed to catalyze that,
that break so that your,
your mother in particular,
but also your father to some degree,
we're no longer the dominant figures of
influenced your,
your personal mother and father were no
longer the dominant figures of influence
in your life.
So because really that's what he
maturation means in some sense is that
when you become an adult,
the opinions of your parents are as
important as the opinions of any other
reasonable people that hypothetically
care for you.
But no more important than that.
So,
and I told you about some of the
symbolic associations that that gather
around say images of the unknown.
You could also think of the unknown as
unexplored territory.
But it's a tricky kind of territory
because if the person beside you does
something spectacularly weird,
you move from explored territory to
unexplored territory as soon as you
don't understand what they're doing.
So it's not exactly spacial temper
territory.
It's more like,
it's more like temporal spacial
territory.
It's time and space because the same
place can be a different place from one
moment to the next.
Now it happens all the time when some
event that you don't expect occurs in
the place that you are so and your body
is prepared to react,
it's instinctively prepared to react to
the emergence of chaotic circumstances.
It basically does that by hyper
activating your preparation for action
and increasing your capacity to pay
attention and preparing you to do a very
large number of things at once because
you don't know what to do.
It's a high stress reaction,
but it's built into you.
And it's so interesting because what
that means that is part of what's built
into people is the ability to deal with
what they don't understand,
which is a real paradox,
right?
Because how can you deal with what you
don't understand?
You don't understand it.
So,
but the answer is,
well,
you,
you ramp up your ability to react in a
very large number of ways and you do
that by increasing your general level of
arousal and your attention.
And it's a good,
that also increases the probability that
you're going to be attentive to new
information and pull it in and utilize
it so that you can decide how to act
rapidly.
So other things happen.
For example,
you know,
some of you may have been in car
accidents or events like that where you
knew for a few seconds that the event
was going to occur and time slowed down.
It's quite a common,
uh,
commonly reported phenomena.
I've experienced it a number of times
actually.
And,
uh,
it was actually experimentally tested.
They,
uh,
threw people off Bungee cord
apparatuses,
you know,
so apparatuses,
so they were plummeting down,
you know,
in a quite frightening manner and had
them look at digital timers that were
flashing information while they were
falling.
And it turned out that the people who
are falling could process the digital
information faster than people who are
just standing there under normal
circumstances.
How they got that passed.
An ethics committee is beyond me,
but,
but it's a brilliant,
it really is a brilliant experiment.
So I went through some of the symbolism
of the unknown.
I want to go through some of the
symbolism that's associated with the
known today.
So give you some sense.
Flags are definitely patriarchal symbols
there.
Their cultural symbols.
And here's some,
I'll just lay out a variety of terms.
And so that'll give you some indication
of the network of associations that's
associated with the symbol of the
dominance hierarchy.
Fundamentally culture,
Apple Linnaean control.
That's after Apollo,
the god Super Ego,
the conscious,
the king,
the patriarch,
the plow.
Cause the plow opens up the earth,
the fellas order and authority and the
crushing weight of tradition,
the wise old man and the tyrant dogma,
the day sky,
the country man,
the island,
the heights,
the ancestral spirits,
and the activity of the dead.
Now these symbolic realms or are kind of
there,
there's there
situationally transformable.
So if you look across very frequently in
stories,
you see characters that exemplify each
of these categories,
but the characters can shift to some
degree.
For example,
so often if the story involves the ocean
and an island than the ocean will be
feminine in Ireland will be masculine.
But if the story utilizes an island and
the air,
then the island will be feminine and in
the air will be masculine.
So it isn't as if there's a one to one
correspondence between the entities in
the story and these archetipal
categories because their definition
depends on,
they can't be defined in isolation.
So it's,
it's,
it's sort of like does this really
stupid example,
but it's the best one I can come up with
at the moment.
If you're trying to interpret
statistics,
you can't understand what a given
statistic means unless you know the
number of people in the experiment,
the effect size and the probability that
that affects size is that at emerged at
a better than chance level.
Any of those pieces of information
without the other two are actually
meaningless.
And it's the same situation here.
You have to have the representation of
culture and you have to have the
representation of nature and you have to
have the representation of the
individual.
And then you can figure out what,
what entities are being used in those
different categories.
Even though there's some similarity
across stories,
which is partly why you could actually
understand stories,
right?
Because if there was no similarity
across them,
then you wouldn't be able to understand
them.
So,
um,
there's some representations of the
great father.
Um,
the,
the one on the left,
which is on the right,
was quite a horrifying image,
you know,
and that's a kind of a devouring father
figure.
And you know,
here,
here's a,
here's a way of thinking about that,
which I think is extremely useful.
So you,
here,
you guys are in university,
you know,
and so,
um,
university is one of those patriarchal
institution that's gives with one hand
and takes away with another,
right?
So when you come here,
there's thousands of you.
There's tens of thousands of view.
So in some sense as an individual,
you're rather faceless and you're also
in some sense at the bottom of the power
hierarchy in the university,
I think more than you should be,
but whatever you,
you are at the bottom of it.
And so there's,
there's a crushing institutional weight
that comes along with being part of such
a big university in particular.
You know,
that's really hard on students in their
first year.
You know,
it's always seemed to me that it's
better for first year students to go to
a smaller place where the institutional
weight is not so heavy.
And you know,
I've tested u of t students in their
first year with things like the Beck
depression inventory and about 30% of u
of t students meet criteria for
hospitalized depression.
They do,
you know,
but,
but that's also because the back is way
more sensitive to that then it should be
at least that,
you know,
because I don't think its criteria for
when you should be hospitalized are
reasonable.
But the point is is that the depression
and the anxiety is quite high.
And so,
but on the other hand,
of course you're benefiting from going
to university.
And so that's the kind of bipolar nature
of the symbol.
It's the tire in town,
it's benevolent tradition.
At the same time,
you know,
it's molding you.
You could even say it's crushing you
because an educational system does that.
But at the same time it's like,
well,
unless you allow yourself to get crushed
by it,
you're not going to get the benefit.
And that's the paradoxical relationship
that individuals have with culture
everywhere.
And at all time.
You know,
without culture you're nothing but with
culture you have to be a cog in some
sense.
And so the tension between those two
things is continual and constant.
You could think about it as an
existential constant ever since there's
been complex human societies and maybe
even when there were only tribal human
societies,
that's been a problem for the
individual.
So culture,
tradition,
the dominance hierarchy is a solution
and a problem and nature,
the unknown,
unexplored territory is a solution and a
problem.
And then the third category,
while you see,
I'll just tell you a couple of things
about these images.
So the one in the right,
that's the devouring father,
that's also giving birth.
So in some sense your personalities are
being devoured by the university,
but at the same time a new personalities
coming,
you know,
emerging as a consequence of that.
And hopefully it's a better personality
than the previous one.
If you can tolerate the tension of being
transformed,
the heat and the pressure,
then hopefully you come out,
you know,
you come out though,
it's worth it.
The process is worth it.
Okay.
Now you know,
you see on the left there at the top on
the,
sorry,
on the right at the top you see a
picture of an old man kissing Joseph
Stalin,
which is quite a weird thing to do.
Given that Joseph Stalin was probably
responsible for the deaths of,
you know,
some number of people in excess of 10
million,
perhaps in excess of 30 million people
argue about this all the time.
He certainly starved 6 million
Ukrainians to death in the 1930s which
is something that you know,
for some reason you don't hear much
about your education but you know,
6 million Ukrainians probably worth
noticing a little bit,
but it doesn't matter because this old
man,
this was taken after the fall of the
Berlin Wall.
He's nostalgic for the times when
everything was certain,
you know,
and the the gold statue of Stella and
his representation in some sense of a
day of five leader.
And the old man is there,
is in a position of worship.
And then Captain Hook there at the
bottom on the right hand side.
He's quite an interesting character
because he's basically a tyrant.
And the Peter Pan Story is very
interesting because Peter Pan Pan sorta
means everything.
And Peter Pan is the sort of person who
wants to retain the dynamic potential of
childhood.
Because when you're a child you're not
anything but you couldn't be anything.
So you're pretty much only potential.
And then you might say,
well why should you sacrifice that
potential to become something actual?
Cause in some sense it's actually a
limiting process.
So,
for example,
and I mean this in the most concrete
possible way,
you have more neural connections when
you're born than you do at any other
time in life.
And most of those die by the time you're
too.
So you go through this tremendous
pruning process from when you're born,
from when,
til two so it's like you're dying into
your childhood personality.
And then again,
the same thing happens at the end of
adolescence between say 16 and 21 which
is also the peak time for risk for the
emergence of schizophrenia.
And some people think that's the pruning
process gone wrong.
But you know,
as an adolescent you also shed childhood
potential to become the limited but
specialized in potentially useful thing
that you will become.
And so you might say,
well,
is it worth it?
Is it worth shedding that potential?
And Peter Pan's answer to that is,
well no,
he wants to remain in Neverland as a
magical boy forever.
And he's king of the lost boys,
which I would say is not a very,
it's not much of a dominance hierarchy,
right?
It's like you're,
you're the king,
King of the King of the losers,
so to speak.
People who can't get their act together
and mature now.
And you notice in Peter Pan,
peter pan doesn't grow up.
He doesn't establish a relationship with
Wendy who's actually real.
He has to settle for Tinkerbell who you
know is a ferry and they don't exist.
And so she's really in some sense of
figure of his imagination because he
won't mature,
he can't have an actual relationship
with,
with a genuine person.
So he has to satisfy himself with,
while it's something like a pornographic
fantasy actually.
So seriously it is,
it is like that.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a toned down a lot in the movie
version obviously,
but still,
that's what's underlying it.
Now you might say,
well why doesn't Peter Pan want to grow
up?
And answer is the only figure of
authority that's around for him.
His P,
his captain hook and he doesn't like
Captain Hook.
And that's because captain hook is a
tyrant.
He's brutal,
you know,
and he's also a coward because he's,
he's lost a hand already to a crocodile
with a clock in its stomach.
That's chaos and time,
you know,
that's the dragon that lives underneath
everything.
It's like the basilisk can Harry Potter
and now Damn Crocodile's already got a
piece of him,
which is exactly the case.
Like that crocodile has got a piece of
me,
you know,
I'm older than 50 and so time is already
God,
its grip on me.
And you know part of the problem of
being adult is that you also have to
take the fact that your finite and
limited into account and if you're
terrified by that,
which people tend to be,
then it can easily turn you into a
tyrant because you're afraid of
everything or disgusted by everything
and you have to ramp up the amount you
control it.
And so Peter Pan looks at Captain Hook
and he thinks there's no damn way.
That's what I want to end up as.
She's got a bad role model,
you know.
So Captain Hook and Stalin in this sort
of devouring monster are good
representations of the negative or
tyrannical element of the great father.
So that's the tyrannical element of the
dominance hierarchy.
So same thing here.
There's Stellan,
you know,
he's the great father of the family and
these,
these kids are,
they're kind of like the Soviet
equivalent of cub scouts.
They're sort of worshiping him.
And then I really liked the other one on
the right because I mean you could
hardly find a more hellish
representation of a tyrant than that,
right?
I mean it looks,
and this is quite interesting,
it looks like Stellan is standing in
front of a man.
Door lock is Amanda Mandela is a shape
like this and allman shape.
You see that renaissance art all the
time.
It's an extremely old symbol.
It's the oldest symbol that people have
ever found evidence for.
And the thing is on fire,
it's like Stella there he is King of
hell.
And it's exactly right.
You know,
it's,
it's eerie that that's the mode of
representation that emerged for them,
but it's certainly accurate.
So you know,
the whole tyrannical end of the great
fathers,
this is the sort of thing that results
from it.
You know,
it's like the,
the
elevation of the person at the top of
the dominance hierarchy to the status of
some kind of cause identity certainly
happened in Hitler's case.
And then the brutal murderousness that
can emerge from that.
Those are pictures from the
concentration camps at the end of World
War II.
So,
you know,
so I told you that the fee,
the feminine can be rep that terrible
unknown things can be represented by the
feminine,
sort of a monstrous figure,
you know,
but it's certainly the case that the
monstrosity of culture is roughly
equivalent to the monstrosity of nature.
You know?
And one of the things you might think
about is that common etiologies tend to
utilize these symbolic categories.
It's almost as if they appropriate them.
So the environmental movement,
for example,
basically says benevolent nature,
right?
So that's the positive feminine negative
culture.
Cause that's cultures out there.
Rapaciously destroying the pristine
wilderness of Mother Nature and the
negative individual too.
Because you know,
human beings are part of that as
individuals and we're kind of a cancer
on the face of the planet if you know,
I mean that's a pretty dark way of
looking at it obviously,
but it's one sided because you can
easily say,
yeah,
well,
you know,
we're in a war with nature because
obviously she's trying to kill us as
fast as possible and we better have some
culture because otherwise we'd be
sitting outside in the freezing snow and
you know,
you might be a rapacious consumer,
but on the other hand you're just trying
to survive and it's not that easy.
And so,
you know,
you need to have both of those stories
together before you have a reasonable
representation of the world.
It's not easy to cope with something
like,
well like that.
It's not easy to cope with something
like that in every institution has this
potential and this element because
institutions tend towards
bureaucratization and tyranny as they
develop,
they close up and become rigid.
And so,
you know,
that's a rough thing to deal with.
And then of course this is a rough thing
to deal with too.
So you might think,
well you could have a little bit of
sympathy for human beings,
not just throw them in the horrible
rapacious creature category,
which I think is an extraordinarily
pathological and also a pre genocidal
thing to do.
You know,
cause you hear environment to lists for
example now and then say the planet
would be better off without people on.
It's like,
well,
you know,
that's kind of what Hitler thought as
well about certain kinds of people
anyways.
And God only knows where he would have
stopped.
So you know,
when someone says something like that,
one of the things you might think is you
should take a good look at your
unconscious structure there.
Bucko because fundamentally you're,
you know,
there is a genocidal ideology at the
bottom of your thoughts structure.
And you know,
you might think that you're an
environmentalist but you're actually
possessed by a genocidal etiology and
you better do something about that
because if you ever get any power,
you're going to be one dangerous
creature.
So one of the things that's really
interesting about psychoanalysis or one
of the things I love about it is that
psychoanalysts tell you,
if someone says I'm good or I stand for
a good thing,
the first thing you want to look for is
the opposite of that.
It's like,
okay,
that's what you say.
What might really be going on?
Or is it actually the case that you're
Jesus Christ and all the saints
combined?
You know,
you're this perfect person or there are
other dark motives for what you're doing
that you claim to be doing for the good.
So guy named George Orwell,
who was one of the world's most creative
essayists in,
in,
in in the 20th century.
He was a,
he was a left winger.
He wrote some things that were very
criticism,
critical of socialist movements and what
did,
it was one of the early critics of
Soviet Russia when it was sort of in
vogue among intellectuals to be
supportive of the Soviets.
One of the things he said about left
wing socialist was that they didn't
really like the poor.
He was talking about middleclass left
wing socialist,
not the working class guys who were in
the unions and you know,
had some justification for their
struggle against those who are at the
top of the power higher.
He was more looking at people that were
already at the top of the power
hierarchy,
who are claiming to be advocates for the
working class.
You know,
and his claim fundamentally was that
those people didn't like the poor.
They just hated the rich.
And you know,
that's the,
it was difficult for the publisher who
was publishing that book,
which was called,
um,
road to Wigan pier,
which is an amazing book.
It's a book about coal miners in
northern,
in northern Britain,
and it's,
it's brutal.
Those people at brutal lives,
man.
So,
but anyways,
uh,
you know,
the publisher,
which was the left book club,
if I remember correctly,
was very low to publish the essay that
went along with that book because it was
such a devastating criticism of sort of
middleclass socialism anyways.
Anyways,
so the psychoanalysts are always telling
you,
look,
you know,
there you are,
there's no monster.
It's like,
okay,
where's the monster?
Because it's somewhere,
it's somewhere because there's a monster
in everyone.
And if you're hiding it or covering it
up or pretending that you know,
you only stand for the good.
It's like all that means is that you're
ignorant and naive about your own
possibility.
There's a monster around there
somewhere.
So
yeah.
And that's partly because,
you know,
if you're not a monster,
it's pretty hard to stay alive because
you know you have to contend with things
like this.
Yeah,
sorry.
Things like this and things like this
and things like this and things like
this,
you know,
that's your life.
You contend with that nature is brutal,
culture is brutal and other people can
be brutal too.
And so if you're not prepared for that
and able to withstand it,
then you're just going to get rolled
over.
So you better get the old inner monster
developed because that under conscious
control,
because even though it's a terrible
thing,
you need it.
So the Taoists for example,
they represent the world
and terms that are quite similar to
those that I just described for you.
So the,
the doubt central Dow assemble is this
one,
the Yin Yang symbol and Yang.
Okay.
Basically stands for order.
That's what it means,
but it means all the things that I've
listed there.
It means order masculinity,
the daytime,
the known,
it also means authoritarianism and
fascism.
And then yen on the opposite side is
chaos.
Femininity,
the night,
the unknown,
decadence denialism.
And it's also a relationship between the
conscious and unconscious.
The current consciousness is represented
by light.
And the reason for that is,
well,
when are you conscious?
Your conscious during the day,
right?
Because we're,
we're,
we're creatures that live in the day,
unlike rats,
for example,
you know,
they live at night.
So for us,
consciousness is associated with
enlightenment and illumination and
daytime and sunrise and the,
and the bright noon sky.
And the unconscious is associated with
the nighttime.
And the reason for that partly too,
is that your unconscious is actually a
lot more active at night.
First of all,
that's when you dream.
And it's also the time when,
if you're a frightened of something or
if you're depressed and ruminative the
frightening thoughts and the depressing
and ruminative thoughts are going to
come up.
So many,
many people have the experience of
waking up in a kind of,
cause.
I cold sweat at three in the morning and
having,
you know,
nothing but it continual stream of
worries run through their head.
And there's pretty good evidence that a
lot of what you're doing at night when
you sleep,
when you're dreaming and when you're not
dreaming is actually processing threat,
you know?
But most of the time you were asleep for
that.
Sometimes you wake up during it and it's
like,
yeah,
it's not something you really want to be
conscious about.
You know,
it's,
it's hard on you.
And it's very,
very common among people who are
depressed,
you know?
So if you want to diagnose someone for
depression,
one of the things you ask them is,
well,
is your sleep chopped up?
You know,
do you wake up multiple times at night
and when you wake up,
what happens if they say,
well you know,
I have worries running through my head
and I can't stop them.
That's rumination cause it's an
automatic process.
It's an unconscious process.
Then you know that the balance between
positive and negative emotion has
shifted too far for that person.
There's so much chaos and pain in their
life or their,
their emotional systems have become
dysregulated that it starting to pop up
into consciousness and dominated.
So now the end Yang symbol is
interesting for a variety of other
reasons too because um,
the Dow was believed that that symbol
represents being now being is not the
same thing as objective reality being is
what you experience as a conscious
creature that's being and for the Dow is
being,
is made up of these two elements,
order in chaos.
And the reason for that,
it's quite straight forward.
The reason for that is wherever you go
and whenever you live and whoever you
are,
each environment that you're in is
composed of things you understand and
things that work the way you expect them
to and things you do not understand.
And that can be,
that can pull the rug out from you at
any moment.
And so you can say in some sense that
these symbolic representations are
representations of the most unchanging
elements of [inaudible].
So the most real things,
because you know,
a typical modern person look at this and
think,
well those aren't real.
It's like they are real.
In fact they're hyper real.
Because one of the things that defines
real is that it's permanent and it is
permanent.
No matter where you go.
There are things you know and things you
don't know.
And it doesn't matter who you are,
it's permanent.
So it's part of the existential
landscape of human being.
Now the other thing that's,
there's two other things that are quite
cool about the and Yang symbol in one is
that the,
each of the black pays,
he has little white dots in it.
And White Paisley has a little black.in
it.
And the reason for that is the Dow is
also recognized quite well that chaos
could turn to order at any moment.
You know,
so a new order can arise out of a
chaotic structure that's like a,
that's a revolution in some sense.
But by the same token,
if you're in a place that's orderly and
predictable,
something can happen that casts you into
a chaotic situation right away.
So there's a dynamic,
even though these two things oppose each
other,
in some sense,
there's a continual dynamic interplay
between them.
And then the final thing that's quite
interesting about this symbol,
this is mindbogglingly brilliant idea,
is that because the dao also means the
way and the way is the line between the
two.
And so what that indicates is,
this is a brilliant idea,
is that the optimal position for a human
being isn't in chaos or in order.
Because if it's too much order,
then it's totalitarian and if it's too
much chaos than it's disgust and fear
and emotional pain and depression.
So where's the proper place and the
dallas dancers right on the line where
you have one foot in order so that
you're fairly stable and you have
another foot in chaos.
So that new and interesting and
compelling and transforming things are
happening to you.
And one of the things that you might
note is that your nervous system
basically tells you when you're there
and the way it tells you is by making
you interested in whatever it is that
you're engaged in.
Because the fact that the thing that
you're engaged in grips you,
which is really an unconscious process,
you can't really control that.
It's something that happens to you is
because your nervous system,
which is actually adapted to the
environment of chaos and order is
telling you that if you're engaged and
interested,
you are at in the place where the
balance between chaos and order is,
is perfect.
Now you think about that,
it's no use reading a paper that you
cannot understand at all.
Even though hypothetically,
that would be a tremendously informative
paper,
right?
But you can't understand it because it's
all chaos to you.
And then there's absolutely no reason
reading a paper,
that tense time.
If you've already extracted the
information out of it,
it's going to be boring.
Okay,
so what do you want?
Well,
you want a paper that you can almost
understand.
So there's,
you know,
you're,
you're the frameworks,
the cognitive frameworks that you have
at hand are sufficient for you to take
the next step into the unknown and the
paper will,
will inform you of that.
And so those are the sorts of things.
Books do that.
Movies do that conversations do that
even lines of thought do that.
If they're exactly at the right level of
complexity for you,
they're going to engage you.
And people know this man.
They know it.
So here's an example.
Let's say you're trying to,
you know,
we could say you're trying to teach your
child to talk,
which of course you don't do what you do
to a child,
just talk to it.
But it's very interesting because there
have been studies of how parents talk to
children and what they do is always use
language that slightly more complex than
the child can understand.
And they do it automatically.
It's part of our,
what a,
in some sense,
our innate knowledge structure about
language.
So you don't only use words that the
child understands,
use words that they understand plus a
few words and phrases and sentence
constructions that they don't.
And so that's sort of pulling them
along.
And a Russian psychologist named the
Gonski called that the zone of proximal
development and the zone of proximal
development is that place.
Cause it's a place in the environment
where information flow into the psyche
is maximized.
And that has to be.
So it has to be,
cause I comprehensible,
you know,
it's something I tried to do in my
lectures.
You know,
I tried to tell you things that you
know,
and associate them with things that you
don't know,
so that you're not swamped,
hopefully by an excess of
incomprehensible information,
but you don't think,
Oh God,
he's saying that again.
I already know that,
you know,
et Cetera,
and anything that's dramatic instructure
is doing that for you.
It's keeping them,
it's keeping you on the edge of
attention.
And that place is where your adaptation
is maximized because not only are you
firming up the structure that's
underneath your feet,
you're relying on it and you know it's,
it's part of the platform on which you
stand,
but you're absorbing information at a
rate that allows you to increase the
solidity and area of that solid ground
without undermining you so much that it
falls apart beneath you.
So it's lovely.
It's such a good idea because think
about what it would mean if it was true.
It would mean that if you pay attention
to what captures your interest and you
follow that,
that means you're going to always be
interested in what you're doing.
But even better than that,
it's going to mean that you're going to
maximize your adaptive capacity as much
as possible at exactly the same time,
man,
that'd be a great deal if it actually
happened to be true.
Now it's a bit complicated because what
culture wants from you and what is
intrinsically interesting to you,
there's going to be a conflict there,
right?
Because culture wants you to do what a
good cultural entities should do,
which is to do what you're told to do,
but you're not,
you know,
you're not a robot.
And so part of the existential problem
that you have in life is trying to
figure out some compromise between what
you find personally engaging and that
develops and supports you and what the
culture will provide,
uh,
resources to you for pursuing.
And it's hard.
There's no simple answer to it.
But I would say that if you sacrifice
your,
your capacity to engage in meaningful
activity to the security of a given
position in a dominance hierarchy,
then you turn into something that's like
a soul,
a slave.
And that's a really bad idea because
there's no way you can do that for any
length of time without getting bored and
resentful.
And once your board and resentful,
the move from that to dangerous is a
very,
very small step.
So it's hard and it isn't even
necessarily the case that you're going
to make the balance.
You know you're going to be able to
manage it,
but if you don't,
you're going to pay a massive price for
it.
So I would say,
you know,
let,
don't let people mess around with what
you find compelling any more than is
absolutely necessary.
You know,
so because it's very dangerous to do
that,
it's very dangerous to do that.
Just like it's dangerous not to find a
position in the dominance hierarchy at
all because then you end up in a chaotic
place.
And my experiences being you,
you might wonder about this,
it's like what's the probability that
someone can live a healthy life,
healthy,
productive,
and stable life outside a dominance
hierarchy.
So without external structure.
And the answer to that is there might be
one person in this class that could do
that.
It's really hard because what happens to
most people is that if they don't have a
substantial amount of external structure
and routine,
they just fall apart.
They don't sleep properly,
they don't eat properly,
you know,
they're depressed.
It's tremendously effortful to
continually reinvent yourself day after
day.
And so there's some real,
there's some real utility in routine and
social identity,
you know,
and young would say the part of you that
has adapted to re routine and social
identity is the persona and sort of the
mask you wear in public and might even
be who you think you are.
And he thought that people who were only
persona,
we're dangerous because they were only
thoughtless advocates of the system for
which they stood.
But he also believed that people who had
no persona,
we're in an equally terrible situation
because they're psychologically chaotic
and they don't have a social structure
around them to hem them in and
continually remind them how to be sane
and productive.
So it's a matter of balance.
You know,
there's,
there's horrors on both sides and
there's advantages on both sides.
And the trick is to place yourself in a
location where you're deriving maximum
advantage from both.
And you'll be able to tell if you do
that.
Because if you are doing that,
you're going to find your life engaging
and meaningful enough.
So the fact that it's also tragic and
potentially composed at least partially
of slavery is going to be acceptable.
And that's what,
that's the goal in some sense.
It's a hard to do that,
but you know,
it's hard not to do it too.
So you're screwed either way.
So you might as well pick the path
that's going to be of maximum utility to
you,
you know,
so and hopefully to everyone else.
Okay,
so this is the individual instead.
So we have explored territory,
unexplored territory or the known and
the unknown or order and chaos.
And then we have the thing that mediates
between them.
And that's the individual.
And this is no medieval representation,
which I really love.
You know,
there's the dome of the sky there.
It's a very archaic idea that the earth
is a dome because it kind of looks like
that if you go out into a flat field,
you know,
if you're out in the ocean,
the way the world looks like a dome on a
disk.
And so that's sort of the representation
here.
It's a very ancient idea.
And this guy at the bottom left of the
picture is poking his head through the
comprehensible world and looking at the
chaos beyond.
And so he's a heroic figure.
So the knower is,
the individual is always the hero of his
story,
right?
The protagonist of historic.
Now it can be an antihero too,
because just like the known has a
negative element and a pause development
and the unknown has a negative element
and a positive element.
The individual has a negative element
And so there's the hero and the
adversary,
roughly speaking.
And you know,
there's all sorts of movies where the
protagonist is an anti hero,
you know?
And those movies are usually there to
show you bad examples in some sense.
Or you get mixed characters like Batman
and he's tangled up with the joker.
And as the joker points out in that
brilliant performance,
they're mirror images of one another.
And so
the jokers and adversary,
it's,
it's more complicated than that.
But so some of the symbols that commonly
represent the individual in symbolic
representations are while,
and also conceptual representations are
ego consciousness.
The trickster bugs bunny is a good
example of a trickster,
the fool,
the hero,
the coward spirit as opposed to matter
or as opposed to dogma,
the son,
the son of the unknown,
and the son of the king.
So,
and those are very,
very common fingers.
And I'll walk you through some of that
as we progress today.
So,
and then there's the figure of the
adversary.
So you see on the right hand,
left hand side there,
you see Horus,
who's the bird headed god of Egypt,
who I told you about,
who represents the capacity to pay
attention.
Very important concept because the
Egyptians realized,
and really it's brilliant.
It is something modern people do not
understand because we tend to make
rationality the highest God that's,
that's not a good thing.
That's a pathway to totalitarianism.
What the Egyptians knew,
but they only knew it in symbolic form
was it was the capacity to attend to
things that in some sense was the
highest psychological function because
it's the capacity to pay attention that
actually moves you beyond what you only
know.
And rationality tends to make,
you know,
integral systems that are coherent,
that are boxlike and then claim that
they're absolutely right.
Whereas the tension has always looking
beyond what you know and,
and attention is an unbelievably
powerful force.
You know,
that's why advertisers pay for it.
That's why people demand it.
That's why children can't live without
it.
That's why it's what you want from your
friends and your family.
You want them to pay attention to you.
It's an unbelievably valuable resource.
And so one of the things I always tell
my clients,
for example,
if they're socially anxious,
I say,
look,
pay more attention to the person you're
talking to.
If you pay,
if you really pay close attention to
them,
then the thoughts that are making you
anxious will be suppressed.
And because you're paying close
attention to them,
you'll match your movements to theirs
and you'll match your conversation to
them.
And then there's no reason for you to be
socially anxious cause socially anxious.
People will go like this when they're
talking,
you know,
they don't want to look at you.
Of course,
how the hell can you engage anyone if
you're not in a little dance with them?
You know,
you can't.
And a lot of it's nonverbal,
it's physical and it's embodied and
without paying attention,
then you lose people.
And you see this with speakers all the
time too.
There in front of audiences,
they have their paper and they're going
like this.
And usually they're talking like this
too.
And you know,
the logical thing to do in that case,
it's like,
look at facebook or get the hell out of
there or something.
But they're not paying attention to the
audience.
And so there's no power in the,
there's no power in the dynamic
conversation at all.
So anyway,
so there's horace and then there's uh,
the guy on the,
on the right there is set and he's like
the precursor of the Christian
representation of Satan.
In fact,
the namesake and seems to have been a
transformation of the name set and set
is actually,
he's like the God of totalitarian
possibility because in Egyptian
mythology he represents the brother,
the evil brother of the rightful king
who's always plotting to overthrow the
rightful king.
And Horace is his natural enemy.
And what this means,
our Italian man,
it's really important.
So I have in my clinical practice
frequently people who are stuck in the
middle of absolutely moronic
bureaucracy.
So I can give you an example of this.
I just love this.
One of my clients who worked for large
corporation,
who's pretty sensible woman,
she is being driven mad by the political
correctness that didn't detected the
organization.
And she sent me a 30 to 32 email letter
exchanges that were circulating around
the word flip chart.
I don't know if any of you have heard
the flip chart conver controversy,
but it's Kurt pretty mind.
Bogglingly moronic and,
and so the deal was that somebody,
you know what a flip chart is,
right?
It's one of those paper pads that you
flip the paper over.
Well it turns out hypothetically that
flip is a pejorative term for Filipinos.
And so they believe that the idea,
the flip chart phrase was no longer
acceptable because it was potentially
offensive to Filipinos,
although I bet they would have had to
like vacuum up the whole planet to find
one Filipino who actually cared whether
or not someone called that a flip chart,
you know?
And that person would have had plenty of
problems that were worse than that.
Anyway,
there was like a 32 serious email
exchanges about what terminology should
be used instead of flip chart,
you know.
So that's what people were doing.
Instead of trying to actually have a
life and do something useful.
And it was driving her completely mad.
They did rename them and made it,
um,
it made part of corporate policy that it
was inappropriate to use the word flip
chart.
I don't remember what the hell they
called them.
Who knows.
But,
but the reason I'm telling you this
story is Lada you are going to find
yourself in bedded in bureaucracies and
you know,
and there's that for better or for
worse.
And one of the things that are going to,
is going to happen to you is that people
are going to ask you to do stupid and
ridiculous things and the fact that
they're asking you to do stupid and
ridiculous things,
it's going to do two things,
three things to you.
One is it a warp you so that you'll
pretend that you agree with it and then
eventually you will and like good so
much for your soul.
And then the other thing is,
is that it will demotivate you because
you'll think,
why should I be s like slaving away at
this job when you know I'm being pecked
to death by morons with stupid rules.
And,
um,
the third thing that it will do is make
you resentful and irritated,
and then that will also undermine your
motivation and make your life miserable.
And so you might think,
well,
what should you do about that?
And the answer to that is you should
object at the earliest possible point
because first of all,
you'll find that if you do,
if you object to radical stupidity when
it first emerges,
you kind of make people aware of the
fact that what they're doing is
radically stupid and they'll usually
back off.
And so then they won't torture you to
death.
So,
you know,
you have to take a risk,
which is,
oh no,
what happens if I complain about this?
But you know,
it's another one of those situations
where you're damned if you do and you're
damned if you don't.
So if you complain,
that'll cause some trouble.
Although usually it causes way less
trouble than you'd think because people
are generally not very courageous.
And if you push them with some strength
on when they're doing something,
absolutely moronic,
they'll usually back off because they
don't know what to do when they're being
challenged.
And then you won't have to put up with
it for the rest of your life.
And so why I'm telling you this is
because all sorts of bureaucratic
entities,
corporations,
government institutions,
um,
nonprofit organizations,
anything that's above a certain size,
cause it doesn't matter if it's
government or corporate,
it's all the same bloody foolishness.
When it gets too big.
It's like those things,
10 towards totalitarian structures.
It's part of,
it's part of their,
the innate danger that's associated with
social organization.
And so then you might say,
well how do you keep the enterprise that
you're part of alive and dynamic and
also keep it a place that a sensible
person who's got,
who's got a proper orientation could
stand to work.
And the answer is do not do things.
You know,
to be stupid.
Stand up and say,
look,
that's dumb.
I'm not doing it.
And if they ask you why,
then you can say,
well a,
I think it's stupid.
B,
if I do it,
I'm going to get irritated and
resentful.
And also if I do it,
it's going to decrease my motivation so
I'm not doing it.
And then if they push you too hard,
it's like,
hey,
it's time for a different job and that
might be the best thing that ever
happened to you because if the,
the structure you're in is going in that
direction and you can't stop it,
it's like get the hell out of there and
find something else.
So it's not that hard to find a job when
you already have a job.
That's another thing to keep in mind
too.
You know,
when ever you're working and you will
be,
especially in the world that the world
of today where jobs are relatively
uncertain is you should always have an
escape route plant and it should be
active because if you don't have an
escape route and you can't get away,
you can't say no.
And if you can't say no,
you can't bargain.
And if you can't bargain,
you're a slave.
So those,
that's how it,
that's how the world is set out at the
moment is probably always been like
that.
But it's something that you really need
to know cause you got to watch if
you're,
if you're being is objecting to someone
to something that someone is forcing you
to do,
maybe you're right,
maybe you shouldn't be doing it.
And lots of people end up living
meaningless lives and that that's a,
that's not a very good term because
there's no such thing as a meaningless
life because one of the meanings of life
is suffering and there's no bloody way
you're going to escape that.
So you will not have a meaningless life.
You'll have a life that's only
suffering.
And I wouldn't recommend that because it
will make you one miserable creature and
plus you'll warp everyone around you
because you'll be vengeful.
So it,
these things are really important.
They're really important.
So all right,
so the individual as like culture and
like nature also has its negative
element.
You would call that the shadow.
You know,
and we're going to,
we're going to discuss the shadow in
some detail because one of the things
that you believed and he kind of got
this idea from nature was that when you
grow up and maybe as a consequence of
your temperament,
you tend to think that some of your
attributes are good and some of them are
negative,
you know,
so you make moral judgements about them.
And Fair enough.
So you know,
you might think for the psychoanalysts,
the two elements of human being that
we're commonly regarded as negative from
a moral perspective where sexuality and
aggression and but humans of notion is
that,
well,
you know,
you might be someone who's modest and
careful and never causes any conflict.
And then we might say,
well you're a well socialized person,
but humans point would be,
yeah,
but you've got no power,
you've got no power.
And so people are just going to roll
right over you.
So you'd better dive into that morass of
sexuality and aggression and pull out
those powers and integrate them into
your psyche so that you can use them
consciously.
Because without that you're harmless.
But you know,
I don't think that's a very good
ambition.
You know,
what do you want to be when you're 30
well,
I want to be harmless.
It's like,
you know,
really that's what you want to be.
It's like you might as well not even be
if that's your goal.
So,
so,
you know,
this dichotomy between the positive
individual and the negative individuals,
very,
very complex because what's positive and
what's negative is not obvious from the
beginning.
And arbitrary judgments don't help.
It's very difficult for a given
individual to look at themselves and
say,
well,
what is it about me that's actually
worth developing?
And I can tie this into some degree into
big five theory.
So one of the big five characteristics
is
agreeableness safe.
And people tend to think of
agreeableness has a virtue,
which is a complete,
it's completely idiotic to think that
because every virtue has its vice.
But agreeable people are sympathetic and
empathetic and compassionate and polite.
And those all sound like good things.
But they're also part of being an
[inaudible] parent by the way.
But,
but anyways,
the problem with being agreeable is that
people take advantage of you and then
you get resentful.
So I'm sure there's a whole pile of you
in here that are agreeable and
resentful.
You know,
I'm sure you know who you are.
And one of the things I would mention,
and you should think about this cause
it'll help you a lot if you do it,
is that resentment is your best friend.
If something makes you resentful,
do not do it.
So,
or there's a more sophisticated rule,
which is if something makes you
resentful,
there's only two possibilities.
One is that you're sniffling and
immature and you won't adopt your
responsibilities and you're whining
about it.
The other is that you're being pushed
around and people are attempting to
enslave you.
So you want to eliminate the first
possibility,
right?
You've got to think,
well,
it might just be an immature and whining
about this.
Is it something that people are
reasonably demanding of me?
And if you think that through and maybe
you talked to some people about it and
you think,
no,
this isn't reasonable,
then the resentment is telling you act,
act cause otherwise that's what you'll
be.
You'll end up 15 years,
especially if you're married or
something like that with 8,000 things
you're resentful about and then you know
you'll be in some kind of painful
divorce that lasts for 10 years.
So better to nip it in the bud.
If someone is after you to do something
and you don't feel like you're getting
proper regard or proper response or you
don't think it's fair,
it's like have some courage and get
ahold of your anger and use it.
Doesn't mean you're right,
but at least it means you can push the
person hard enough so they have to
engage in a dialogue with you and you
know this is,
these are necessary skills.
Like if you cannot do this,
you have to be able to say no to
negotiate.
You have to be able to say no.
So you always want to put yourself in a
position where you can do that.
That's part of being,
that's part of power and the other thing
is do not let people push you around
because you'll get pushed right into a
corner and you'll end up as a slave and
that's because there's tyranny,
slavery or negotiation.
That's what you've got.
Yes.
Then you're looking at it from the wrong
perspective.
Your,
your,
your level of analysis is wrong because,
so you know it is society as a whole,
but what the hell good is that going to
do you,
you can't complain to society as a
whole.
You have to look for the micro
manifestations that actually occur in
your realm and work on those and that's
the only level of analysis you have any
control over anyways.
Fix the things that are within your
realm of power and what will happen as a
consequence of that is that your realm
of power will grow but you start local
because like what the hell do you know?
You're 19 or 20 or whatever it is,
like have,
you'll have a scrap with society.
It's like that's just an architectural
problem.
That's all it is.
Because you don't know enough about
society to have that opinion.
You know?
And I'm not being,
I'm not being like,
I'm not trying to be cynical about this.
I am telling you that it's an
architectural problem.
You know?
Of course,
everybody who is young has a problem
with society.
You're all at the bottom of the bloody
dominance hierarchy unless you count the
entire rest of the world,
in which case you're already in the top
1% right?
So,
you know,
that's where thinking about too.
So when you know,
if you,
if you are in involved in a battle,
in some sense with society,
you,
you're dominated by the figure of the
great father,
the negative figure of the great father.
You also have to a lot of what you
should do about that.
It's increased your level of gratitude.
You know,
here you are.
It's warm.
The chair works.
The floor isn't going to fall apart,
right?
You're at a prestigious institution.
You're well on your way to being one of
the top 1% in society.
You're just too damn in the young right
now for that to happen.
You're smart,
you're healthy.
You're good looking except for that
weird thing you're wearing around your
head.
So like,
you know what the hell,
it's,
everything's good for you.
So I mean,
I know there's a tyrannical element
there is.
It's real,
but,
but if that's all you see,
you're,
you're blinded and that's not good.
It'll warp you.
So,
okay,
so here's an example of how people
automatically see the world as animated.
So it makes sense.
So,
you know,
cause I said we automatically perceive
the world in personifies category.
So let's look at this.
Okay.
So I would say that's the beginning of
the journey into the unconscious.
So that's there.
He's going,
what would you say into the underworld
fundamentally.
Okay.
So the first thing you notice that you
can all understand that,
right?
It's sort of like the world of
childhood,
but it makes sense for all those things
to be,
to be animated,
to manifest themselves in personified
form.
It's a way,
it's a way of looking at the world that
we can really understand and it's a
natural way.
Sorry about that.
It's a natural way for children to,
to look at the world.
All their books are like that.
Everything's animated because that's,
that's what they assume about the world.
That's the first understanding of the
world,
is the world of a place of
personalities.
And they have to move beyond that to
start developing some concept of the
objective world.
And it isn't even clear that that's
necessary.
So
okay,
so now I would say that that's,
what would you call,
that's part of the symbolic structure
that represents the shamanic initiation.
So I'm going to read something for male
Iata,
which is one of the readings that you
have,
I should like even now to stress the
fact that the psychopathology of the
shamanic vocation is not profane.
It does not belong to ordinary
symptomatology.
So what he's saying is that it's not
psychopathological,
it's part of normative personalities
development.
It has an initiatory structure,
significant and signification.
In short,
it reproduces a traditional mystical
pattern.
The total crisis of the future.
Sharman sometimes leading to complete
disintegration of the personality and to
madness can be evaluated not only as an
initiatory death,
but also as a symbolic return to the pre
cosmic gornick chaos to the amorphous
and indescribable state that precedes
any cosmogony cause.
Margariney is the account of the initial
creation of being.
So in the Judeo Christian tradition,
for example,
that would be the emergence of order out
of the initial state of chaos.
That's,
that's produced by God's words.
So,
and that's another symbolic
representation.
There's chaos,
there's the active word and there's
order.
And those are the three initial elements
of being.
And so the Sharman in some senses,
reducing himself as a consequence of
exposure to something radical to the
initial components of his being.
And then being reconstructed out of
that.
And that happens to you all the time.
In some sense,
when you encounter an obstacle that
really sets you back because you know
you've ordered the world and then what
you find out is the ordering of the
world is incorrect.
And before you can reorder it has to
become chaotic.
It does become chaotic.
That's what sets you back.
And then out of that chaos you have to
bring out a new order.
If you can't,
you know.
So for example,
you get betrayed by someone that you
love.
It's like,
okay,
it's time to update your world model now
can you,
well maybe not,
you know,
because if you really update it,
you have to come.
You have to come to terms with the fact
that the individual,
which would also include you is capable
of radically immoral act because
betrayal is a radically immoral,
locked,
right.
If there's any thing that's actually a
moral,
it's people telling you one thing and
then doing a whole bunch of other things
behind your back.
And then that brings up a question,
which is,
well,
how the hell can people be like that?
Especially because I'm also a person.
And then also how can I be so naive and
moronic that that can happen to me?
So,
and those are not trivial questions.
You know,
if you can't,
if you don't have an answer to them at
hand,
what it means is that there's half the
world you haven't mapped out,
which would be the negative half.
And you may have to revisit and revise
and destroy virtually all of your
assumptions about the world.
So that's a reduction to chaos.
It is not fun,
especially if it happens accidentally
and it can be traumatic enough so you
never recover from it.
Post traumatic stress disorders like
that,
like if you watch soldiers in battle and
they get post traumatic stress disorder,
it's very frequent that they get it
because of something they did not
because of something that happened to
them.
You know,
so they're out on a mission of some sort
and they shoot a three year old child.
It's like,
and maybe they do it consciously and
then you know,
they wake up after they do it and they
think,
well that's not me.
It's like,
Oh yes it is.
It's just not the you that you think you
are and the you that did that man in
countering,
that's going to be enough to damage your
consciousness.
And that is what happened to people with
post traumatic stress disorder.
Like it blows them apart so badly and
not just psychologically right?
It,
it radically alters them physiologically
their amygdalas grow in their
hippocampus by shrink.
If you have post traumatic stress
disorder,
it's a whole brain transformation.
It's like it's no joke.
And the human capacity for evil is so
deep that,
well young,
for example,
he thought that that,
uh,
you know,
an accidental encounter with it was
enough to well enough to lead to madness
in some cases.
And it's,
it's no joke.
All right,
so here's the way of thinking about
things.
I'm going to move through it relatively
quickly.
So,
um,
you look through the world,
you look at the world through a frame of
reference,
and the reason you do that in part is
because there's more to the world than
you can understand.
And so that would be the actual chaos of
the world.
It's like the world is very,
very,
very complicated.
And you know,
you're a very complicated too,
but you're not as complicated as the
world.
So you're continually surrounded by a
chaotic structure that you don't really
understand.
And you have to frame it in with a frame
of reference that only allows you to see
those things that are necessary for you
to see at the time of your given action.
And as far as I can tell,
this is a cybernetic model of
personality.
The elements of that frame or something
like this is a basic story.
You are somewhere,
you're located somewhere in time and
space,
always.
You know where that is and you have some
sense of the qualities of that
localization.
So people ask you about that because
they ask you,
well,
how are you doing?
And what they're asking is,
you know,
what's your representation of your
current state of being?
And the answer to that is generally for
people,
um,
it's okay,
but it's insufficient because if it
wasn't insufficient,
while what,
why,
why would you be doing anything in any,
in principle now isn't good enough
because there's something else that
could be better.
And that's what you're pursuing.
And if it's kind of a weird thing
because it means in some sense that if
you weren't dissatisfied permanently,
you wouldn't be motivated to do
anything.
And so that's also part of the reason
that a lot of human being human
experience is characterized by somewhat
negative emotions.
It's like this,
we're permanently dissatisfied.
Why?
Well,
because we can act to change things.
So if you're not dissatisfied,
you don't want it to be better.
So in some sense,
what you're doing is looking at the
world through a frame that says this is
what there is and here's how I evaluated
and here's what could be and that's what
I want.
I would like to bring that about.
And so that's uh,
that's what gives things value.
It gives things value because things
that will move you to where you want to
go,
they have a positive value and things
that get in your way when you're trying
to get to where you want to go,
they have a negative value.
And so that's partly how your emotions
work.
So,
and you can put almost anything in the,
in the box of what should be,
it's weird because normally animals,
what would be in the box of what should
be,
would be deep motivational states that
are biological in origin.
So maybe an animal hasn't had enough to
eat.
And so park,
it's feeling hungry.
That's undesirable.
It wants to have something to eat.
And so these different underlying
biological systems like hunger and
thirst and,
and sexual lost and aggression and
temperature regulation and so on.
There are what set the goals and the
perceptual frame.
So,
and the emotional responses.
But in human beings we're so damn
abstract that we can take that structure
and we can put almost anything in that
goal box.
So for example,
you can go to a soccer game and you can
say,
well,
I'm going to identify with my team.
So you expand the boundaries of your
current state of existence to
incorporate the team.
And then you say,
well,
it's really important to me that these
kicked that little round sphere through
that net.
And so your whole nervous system says,
okay,
well if that's the goal,
we're going to align our emotions with
that.
And then you know,
guys you don't know,
run down the field and kick a little
sphere through a nat and you're like up
there,
you know,
and celebrating in a way that you'd
never do in your actual life.
It's like you don't do that when you get
a good grade on an exam,
you know,
jump up in the air and hug all your
friends.
It's,
you'll do that at a soccer game.
It's like what the Hell is wrong with
you?
So,
but you do that because this is a very
malleable and extendable frame and
you're using it for everything.
When you go into a movie theater and you
watched the protagonist,
you basically adopt his or her frame of
reference and then you see the whole
world that's portrayed on the screen
through the eyes of the person that
you're identifying with as part of our
capacity for imitation.
So basically what you do,
what it seems,
what you do there is like if you're
talking to someone else and you adopt
their frame of reference,
it's not exactly a cognitive operation.
What you seem to do is first of all come
with to some understanding about what it
is that they want.
And so that's the goal.
Once you know what they want,
you can represent them in your body.
So it's almost like you're playing them
as a simulation on your own biological
plot form.
And then you can infer from your own
emotional responses if you also simulate
the situation that they're in,
what their emotions are.
And that enables you to understand other
people's.
So were these weird biological computers
that are capable of running other
psyches on our biological platform.
And that makes us able to imitate and
also to understand each other.
So that's a basic narrative.
I was here and I'm trying to go there.
And so if you're asking your
kindergarten kid what they did today at
school and teaching them to tell a
story,
they might say,
well,
I was at home and then mom took me to
kindergarten.
It's like not a very exciting story,
but it's a story.
And then a little more exciting story
might be,
I was at home,
my mom took me to school and on the way
there a big dog ran up to the fence and
barked out me and the right question
that would follow that story is,
okay,
what did you do?
And that's a real story because the kid
says,
well look,
I was in this frame of reference and I
was aiming at goal a b actually I was
aiming at point b and while I was aiming
at point b an acting out the processes
that would lead me there,
something unexpected happened.
That's a story.
And then you say,
well what did you do?
And the kid might say,
well,
you know,
I was really scared and I hid behind mum
or so that would be one response.
And we still went to kindergarten and I
was okay,
it's pretty good,
pretty good.
Or The kid might say,
well I wasn't scared at all because I
know that if you stand up to dogs,
they usually leave you alone.
And we went to kindergarten and that was
okay.
And you know,
the kid is trying to tell really they're
trying to tell a little hero story and
if they're successful in the accounter
with the thing that's unknown,
then they try on as a consequence of
their encounter with the unexpected and
Poof,
you know,
that's successful out of pace.
You Pat them on the head and you say,
yeah,
no that's really good.
They kind of smile and you know,
you're teaching them,
you're teaching them how to comprehend
their existence in a narrative structure
and you're also teaching them what that
narrative structure should be.
So this is like a Meta narrative and the
Meta narrative says you were going from
point a to point b.
That's the oval on the left.
And then something completely bizarre
happened.
Like I was betrayed and then I was in
this terrible place for quite a long
period of time,
a chaotic place.
But I learned a bunch and I put myself
back together and I'm a wiser person as
a consequence of the encounter.
Right?
Everyone knows that story.
And that's paradise.
Paradise lost,
paradise regained.
It's a cultural meta-narrative and,
and it's a story that every,
like it's a human story.
It's an apocalyptic story.
That's why everybody's always all
apocalyptic about everything,
right?
Apocalypse of the week,
we're going to run out of oil.
We're going to run out of gas.
There's too much carbon dioxide.
The Chinese are going to take over the
world.
We're ruining the,
we're ruining the ecology,
the oceans running out of fish.
You know,
the world is getting too hot.
It was getting too cold in 1970 when I
was about your age.
It's like apocalypse of the week.
Why?
Because things fall apart and because
they can fall apart completely and they
often do.
And so everyone's always on the alert
for like the next potential apocalypse
and it's no wonder,
you know,
it's a permanent characteristic of life
that things can radically fallen apart.
Now Luckily it's a permanent
characteristic of life that they can
actually also radically come back
together.
And it turns out that whether or not
they radically come together,
depends to some degree on how you choose
to act when they fall apart.
What is the pre cosmic Garnett chaos.
This is from,
um,
William James,
who was a pragmatist,
lived on the east coast at about the end
of the 18 hundreds.
He was one of the founders of modern
psychology.
He likes to sniff nitric nitrous oxide,
which is a hallucinogen.
He was sort of like the world's first
major league hippie and he wrote sort of
hippie poetry as a consequence of his
nitrous oxide experimentation.
And here's part of what a he derived
from his experiences.
So,
um,
pure experience is the name which I give
to the original flux of life before
reflection has categorized it only
newborn babes and persons in semi coma
from sleep,
drugs,
illnesses,
or blows can have an experience pure in
the literal sense of awe that which is
not yet any definite what potential
potential cause he might think,
well,
what's the world made of?
It's made out of actuality,
right?
That's not how you act.
You Act as if the world's made out of
potential and you interact with that
potential.
And what James is saying is that there
are times when you experience something
that's akin to relatively pure
potential,
and then you might ask yourself whether
or not potential is real,
which is a really interesting question,
but I can say regardless of how you
answer that question,
you act as if it's real and you'll also
feel guilty of someone that you love,
comes up to you and says,
you're not living up to your potential.
It's like,
what the hell does that mean?
What does it mean?
It means you're not becoming that which
you could be.
Well,
what is that?
It's like,
you know,
we're materialists.
How are we going to measure that?
You can't touch it.
You can't taste it.
You can't see it.
You can't measure it.
Right?
But,
but nonetheless,
it's like the substance of being and
being his potential as well as
actuality.
And we're grappling always with the
potential.
And so that's what James is talking
about.
Pure potential.
I like to think of it as latent
information full both of oneness and
menace,
but in respects that don't appear
changing throughout yet.
So confusedly that it's phases.
Interpenetrate sounds like the Yin and
Yang symbol and no points either of
distinction or of identity can be
caught.
Here's his poem.
No verbiage can give it because the
verbiage is other incoherent,
coherent the same and it fades and it's
infinite.
It's infinite.
Don't you see the difference?
Don't you see the identity constantly?
Opposites united the same.
Me telling you to write and not to
right.
Extreme,
extreme,
extreme something.
And other than that thing,
intoxication and otherness than
intoxication.
Every attempted betterment,
every attempted other men is a,
it fades and it fades forever and
forever as we move.
Elliot says now,
as we know for archaic and traditional
cultures,
the symbolic return to chaos is
equivalent to preparing a new creation.
So the death of your current state of
being can be the preparation for a new
being.
Now one of the things the psychoanalysts
say,
and this is implicit in Elliot's
discussion of the show transformation,
is if you do this voluntarily,
you have a much better chance of doing
it successfully.
So the rule is,
well,
if you go to hunt for a dragon and
you're in pretty good shape while you're
doing it and you're all prepared,
then the damn thing might not eat you.
But if you're lying in bed and you know
you're covered with cheesy dust and
you've,
you're hung over from three days worth
of drinking,
then the dragon,
we'll just eat you.
And it's probably a good thing for
everyone that it did.
So,
so the point is be prepared.
And part of the way that you're prepared
is by being awake and having the,
uh,
many sources of power that are at your
fingertips that are part of your
biological and cultural inheritance at,
at the ready so that you can respond.
Yeah,
it follows that we may interpret the
psychic chaos of the future.
Sharman has a sign that the profane man
is being dissolved and a new personality
being prepared for birth transformation,
constant theme,
Paradise,
lost and redemption.
That's the story of mankind.
We're in a fallen state.
Why is that?
While,
because things aren't perfect and they
could be better and everyone's
suffering.
So things have fallen apart.
They're always in the state of being
fallen apart.
And what are we trying to do?
What we're trying to put them back
together.
That's the eternal story of mankind
that,
yeah.
Now on [inaudible] who was an
existentialist psychotherapist,
um,
and who is a leader of the
existentialist movement in the 1950s and
also a profound student of
psychoanalysts.
Psychoanalysis talked about something he
characterized as a creative illness,
which was something that manifested
itself in Freud and in [inaudible] and
in other people like Viktor Frankl for
example,
who went through periods of extreme and
Darwin,
extreme periods of chaotic disruption
has their new theories were manifesting
themselves because the new theories tore
them apart as they were being developed.
And they paid a tremendous personal
price for that.
But generally they were able to
reorganize themselves within the context
of the new theory.
And that made their stance more powerful
and more complete than it was before he
described the characteristic elements of
the creative illnesses follows.
It succeeds a period of intense
preoccupation with an idea and search
for a certain truth.
It's a polymorphous condition that can
take the shape of depression,
neurosis,
psychosomatic ailments,
or even psychosis,
whatever the symptoms they are felt as
painful,
if not agonizing by the subject with
alternating periods of alleviation and
worsening throughout the illness.
The subject never loses the thread of
his dominating preoccupation.
It's often compatible with normal
professional activity and family life,
but even if he keeps to his social
activities,
he's almost entirely absorbed with
himself.
He suffers from feelings of isolation,
even when he has a mentor who guides
them through the ordeal like the showman
apprentice with his master,
the termination is often rapid and
marked by a phase of exhilaration.
The subject emerges from his ordeal with
a permanent transformation in his
personality and the conviction that he
has discovered a great truth or a new
spiritual world.
Also happened to piaget.
Many of the 19th and 20th century
figures recognized universally is great
niche,
a Darwin,
Dostoevsky,
tolstoy,
Freud Young.
We're also additionally characterized by
lengthy periods of profound
psychological unrest and uncertainty.
Here's our dream that my daughter had
when she was three,
and this is quite a cool dream.
I caught it.
I was able to write it down verbatim
because I was writing at the time.
So she came in to tell me this dream.
So I typed it out because it's not that
easy to catch a kid's dream.
So here was the situation.
So when we brought her brother home from
the hospital,
he is two years younger than her.
We didn't know,
you know,
if there's less than a three year gap
between siblings,
there's a high probability of sibling
rivalry because the old siblings still
needs a lot of attention.
But you know when you have a two year
old you think man that's a baby.
But when you bring a newborn baby home,
that two year olds in adult,
like there's such a radical difference
between a newborn and a two year old.
And so it's hard on the two year old,
right?
Cause they have to grow up right away
and maybe they don't get as much
attention.
So we taught her to,
we taught her to come for a hug when she
needed to by practicing that.
And we also prepared her and told her
that,
you know,
there was going to be some trouble but
she could get some attention from this
new baby.
And that was also her baby.
So she was all prepared for that.
So she took a lot of care of that baby
and she thought it was her baby and she
liked this baby.
And so she called him baby and then,
you know,
he started to toddle around and,
and uh,
and we told her one day,
well,
he was being toilet trained.
We said,
look,
Mckayla,
he's not really a baby anymore.
And she didn't like that because she
thought,
hmm,
I like that baby.
And now whatever this creature is
apparently is not that baby.
And so what am I supposed to do about
that?
And not as a profound question because
there are lots of parents who don't let
their children progressed past the stage
of baby because they don't want to lose
the baby.
And so it's like she was onto something
major.
So,
um,
so this is what she said.
This is your dream.
Julian is the name of her little
brother.
Julian's eyes fall down.
And then he falled into pieces and I
said,
what,
what sort of piece is?
And she said Julian pieces.
It's like,
yeah.
And then his bones falled out too.
Then a whole goddess and there was water
in it.
And when he came out he was big and my
wife said,
Julian isn't a baby anymore.
And Mckinley said,
no,
he's a big boy and above with legs.
Got Him out cause bugs can swim and the
hole was in the park and the park and it
moved into the backyard and he felt he
falled in it.
A tree burned and left the hole.
So that was pretty cool.
Like grade three,
you know,
three year old kid.
And so the park,
they started,
her place was 42 acres and it was like a
real forest and park.
And I used to take the kids there like
at twilight and you know,
we'd creep around in there and it was
pretty scary and exciting for them.
So it was sort of an ex gary and
exciting place.
It was full of trees.
And so it was the unknown outside of our
little house.
And so her dream said,
well the unknown had moved into the
backyard in the form of a tree and the
tree burned down.
And a tree is often a symbol of the
psyche.
And it left the hall and the hall was
full of water and then the little baby
went into the water,
dissolved and went into the water.
And then this weird bug got him out.
So it was some alive thing bug.
It's actually,
it was a bug like Jimminy cricket in
Pinocchio,
You know,
cause that's a bug and it's a bug that
leads transformation by the way.
So anyways,
the bug got him out and then he was a
big boy and what she was dealing with
was the nature of radical
transformation.
How one thing could turn into something
different and then reconstitute itself
as something else.
And she did that on a symbolic level.
So what time is it?
Three rats.
All right,
well I'll tell you this little story for
one minute.
So I had a five year old nephew and he
was having night terrors.
So we'd wake up at night screaming and
having a lot.
And uh,
there was some trouble in his family at
that point.
His parents ended up getting divorced,
but anyways,
he'd wake up screaming.
And so he also was running around during
the day with a little night hat on and
like a plastic sword.
And so he goes like Joe night,
you know,
and,
and then when he went to bed,
he had the little night hat by him and
also the sword.
And so one night when I was there,
he had one of these night terrors.
And so I will,
I was there that morning and I said,
well,
did you dream anything?
And this is what he said,
dwarf like beat creatures who came up to
his knees,
had he was out in the field and they
were like,
so these little things about this big,
they had no arms,
they just had a big head that was beaky
a beak and they were jumping at him with
the beak and like chomping him.
And on the top of their head they had,
it was all hairy and greasy and on the
top of their head they had a cross
shaved in it.
So it was like everybody shut up at that
breakfast,
I can tell.
It's like,
oh that's what's happening.
It's no one to wonder.
You're screaming.
And then so he is fighting away with
these things and they're jumping on
them.
But the problem was he said he,
there was a dragon in the background and
what was happening was the dragon was
breathing out fire all the time and the
fire and the smoke,
we're turning into these dwarfed,
you know,
little dwarf bird things that were
biting them and it's like perfect.
Right.
It's such a perfect representation.
He can't fight off any one problem cause
it's sort of pointless because there's
something in the background generating
problems like mad.
It's like a hydro cut off one head,
seven more grow.
So I said,
what could you do about that?
Which is a leading question,
right?
Because it implies that he could do
something about that.
So then he said,
I would take my dad and we would go
after the dragon.
I jumped on his head and poke his eyes
out with my sword and then I go down its
belly to where the fire comes out.
And I'd carve out a piece of the firebox
and I'd make a shield out of it.
And I thought,
yes,
that's right.
So,
and one of the things that's very
interesting,
and I know this is hard to believe,
but it's absolutely true.
He did not have any night terrors after
that was extra cool.
And it was the leading question.
It's cause he's like victim,
right?
It's like,
oh my God,
horrible bird headed biting things,
you know,
which is pretty good.
It's like that's what the world's like.
And then there's something in the
background generating these things.
What do you do?
You go to the source of the trouble and
you find something that shields yourself
from it in the encounter.
Brilliant.
All right.